hello guys and gals Mary here with the  game spot news update and I've got the  top 10 highest selling games of 2014  sales include physical retail numbers  across all platforms including PC here  are your top 10 highest sellers of 2014  call of duty ghosts FIFA 15 watchdogs to  leave a memory NBA 2k15 super smash bros  minecraft grand theft auto 5 destiny  madden NFL 15 and your number one call  of duty advanced warfare overall game  sales were up in the US hitting 13.1  billion dollars of one percent from 2013  12.9 for billions coincidentally  watchdogs was also on my top 10 list of  ways to burn sixty dollars in 2014 for  more gaming news go to gamespot com  splash news